since the 5p charge on single-use
plastic bags came into force three years
ago our dependence on them has plummeted
which is why some are questioning the
need to go further it's been a huge
success 85% reduction amongst the
biggest retailers but there's still more
to go so we think that and asking
people's views on this by doubling it to
temperance it will be that extra
incentive for people to stop relying on
buying a plastic bag at their local shop
the Chancellor Philip Hammond is amongst
others reported to be unhappy about what
some view as another shopping tanks but
we've already seen that there's been
quite a decrease in the use of these
bags already so the idea that we have to
double it again it just seems to be
another I think unnecessary tax and
charge hitting consumers and taxpayers
there's no doubt we are using billions
fewer throw away plastic bags than in
the past and the money paid for those we
do buy has raised more than a hundred
and fifty million pounds for charity in
the process but price doesn't seem to be
the only go indeed major determining
factor the latest government figures
show the big seven retailers doled out
1.0 four billion single-use plastic bags
in the year 2017 to 18 down from 1.3
three billion the year before but if you
strip out the figures from Tesco the
biggest retailer which stopped offering
single use bags altogether
the total for the remaining six actually
went up by more than fifteen million
green campaign is a lukewarm about the
government's latest plan EMA priests
learned from friends of the earth says
plastic bags are not the biggest plastic
problem in our shops and charging for
plastic bags is really just the tip of
the iceberg we're using plastic in such
irresponsible ways as supermarkets or
some of the worst offenders of this they
need to provide more Goods loose in bulk
so that people can bring their own
containers and they need to stop using
plastic that cannot be recycled in an
easy way
environmental groups believe the easiest
way to purge single-use plastic bags
from our shops is not to charge for them
but to ban their use in the first place
dari boatman Sky News